One possibility for increasing the initial compromise rate,
or designing a very fast spreading worm, is
to create a hit list, or a list of vulnerable hosts ahead of time. That curve
we just saw shows that the time to
infect the first 10,000 hosts dominates infection time.
So if we start by performing stealthy scans
or some reconnaissance to construct a list of
vulnerable hosts before we start spreading, then
we can get rid of that initial flat
part of the curve where the worm is
effectively dormant. The second approach is to use
something called permutation scanning Where every compromised
host has a shared permutation of an IP
address list to scan for vulnerabilities. Now if
this list is randomly permuted and a particular
host starts scanning from its own IP address in the list And works down,
then different effected hosts will start scanning
from different parts of this list ensuring
that compromised hosts don't duplicate each other's
work. One worm that exploited these techniques
to spread particularly quickly was the Slammer
worm, which spread in January of 2003.
Exploiting a buffer overflow in Microsoft's SQL
sever. In addition to using fast scanning techniques,
the entire slammer code fit in a single small UDP packet. The UDP packet contain
the worm binary, followed by an overflow
pointer back to itself. It would say classic
buffer overflow combined with random scanning. Once
the control is passed to the worm code,
it randomly generated IP addresses and attempted to
send a copy of itself to Port 1434
on other hosts. One brilliant aspect of the
slammer worm, is that because it was spread
by via single UDP packet, it was connectionless,
meaning that it could spread. And was no
longer limited by the latency of network round
trip time, but only by the bandwidth of
the network, the worm caused $1.2
billion dollars in damage, and temporarily knocked
out many elements of critical infrastructue, including
Bank of America's ATM network. An entire
cell phone network in South Korea, and five route DNS servers, as well as
Continental Airlines' ticket processing software. The worm
actually did not have a malicious payload,
but the bandwidth exhaustion on the network caused resource exhaustion on
all the infected machines. Here's a picture of the hosts around
the world that Slammer infected. This damage was inflicted in just
thirty minutes, due to the very lightweight nature in which Slammer spread.